[Music]
Kitt's
toys are made to educate develop the
child's motor skills and show them
everything is possible and sometimes
they're just there to keep them busy for
a couple of minutes some of these toys
are so popular you can even open a
business by making them yourself do you
want to know why the fidget spinners are
so popular watch this video to find out
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and give this video a big thumbs up
today we're discussing 10 most addictive
toys kids love hoverboards let's start
with the toy that made its way into
every household in a very surprisingly
short amount of time since its launch
this toy might have had a short-lived
Fame but while it was popular it was
definitely addictive hoverboards were a
look into the future and everyone wanted
to be a part of it the hoverboard first
successfully launched in 2015 and the
idea came from the already established
Segway which is a two-wheeled
battery-powered vehicle makes a Segway
and a skateboard and you'll get the
hottest toy on the 2015 market and just
about every celebrity was using them
from Justin Bieber and Martha Stewart to
every social-media influencer the
hoverboards were an exciting way of
getting to experience how we might use
transportation in the future riding a
hoverboard might require some skill as
there is nothing to hold on to you just
step on it and control the speed and the
direction by using your feet sure they
might not have been for those in the old
age but they provided tons of fun for
just about everyone else so what
happened to the hoverboards and why did
the trend decline during their sudden
popularity many reported that
hoverboards started several fires as
they were charging from then onward the
hoverboard was no longer declared as a
safe to use toy but don't worry we're
pretty sure hoverboards will be making a
comeback slime if you're looking for a
toy that's more suitable for the
youngest crowd slime is a popular
alternative and nowadays it's not just
limited to the younger generation think
of it as a modern-day play-doh with even
crazier colors glow-in-the-dark options
and an
added mysterious element of fun but the
slime actually became much more than
that the internet seems to be completely
obsessed with making it seeing it being
made touching it or simply just watching
slime videos this odd creation has been
around for quite a while but for some
strange reason it became increasingly
more popular over the last few years
slime also opened doors to entrepreneurs
yep you heard that right because it's so
popular people can start their very own
slime business and sell the ingredients
to make slime these ingredients usually
include white glue blue coloring water
and borax powder but you can also easily
make a glow-in-the-dark slime by adding
the glow-in-the-dark paint and some
polyvinyl alcohol slime is also becoming
increasingly popular as it can act as a
wonderful de-stress tool perhaps this is
exactly why the younger generation got
so crazy over something as simple as
gooey unique textured sludge Tamagotchi
Tamagotchi first launched in 1996 and
was marketed as the first virtual pet
it's the toy most people living in their
nineties got to play with at least once
if you're not familiar with Tamagotchi
here's all you need to know their
digital pets that look like eggs once
you activate your toy you'll need to
take care of your Tamagotchi
this also means virtually playing with
it and eating it just like a real-life
pet who would have thought that taking
care of a virtual pet would become such
a hit the company behind Tamagotchi sold
more than 76 million units worldwide
well here's some good news for those who
missed Tamagotchi and those who never
got the chance to play it it's coming
back for its 20th anniversary the
company rereleased the virtual pet game
with the same six original characters
and named it Tamagotchi friends we bet
every 90's kid will rush to get their
hands on the toy from their childhood
but do you think Tamagotchi has a chance
to charm the younger crowd to get with
the modern times you can now also play
this digital pet game on your Apple
watch and any other Apple and Android
device Pokemon but if you're not a fan
of the Tamagotchi you might be more fond
of the next toy from a cartoon show -
Nintendo
games trading cards and even the app
that made the world completely obsessed
over this media franchise its pokemon
pokemon is one of the most beloved
franchises out there and it's still just
as popular as it was in the past whether
it's through the Pokemon Go app or the
trading cards the Pokemon lives on did
you know that Pokemon Go was one of the
most popular apps in 2016 and its total
revenue was more than 1 billion by
January 2017 with more than 20 million
daily active users Pokemon go was played
all around the world the age of the
players ranges anywhere from 13 to over
50 although many users have stopped
playing the game after the 2016 summer
launch it is still just as popular and
addictive for those who love the world
of Pokemon did you know an average user
spent about 43 minutes playing the game
on a daily basis and you better get
ready because new updates guarantee even
more fun with the Go app gotta catch em
all leggo when it comes to the most
popular and addictive toys of all time
you know we need to put Lego on this
list
Lego lets you build just about anything
which is probably why it's so popular
there's just something very addictive
about putting together block after block
and ending up creating a unique object
Lego was created in 1949 in Denmark and
it quickly became one of the most
popular toys on the planet pop quiz time
how many Lego facts do you know give
yourself a point for each correct answer
do you know in how many countries Lego
is sold and how many colors you can find
on the bricks 130 countries and 53
colors how many pieces are out there
from 1958 to 2013 six hundred and fifty
billion pieces were made and four
billion of those belonged to mini
figurines what is the tallest Lego
structure
it's a tower built by Lego Italia in
2015 and it measured a hundred and
fourteen feet and 11 inches tall which
is the largest model it's this awesome
x-wing made out of an impressive 5.3
million bricks the thing weighs 23 tons
it took 32 builders over 17,000 hours to
create this masterpiece did you know
that the LEGO Group is actually the
second popular toy maker in the world
the first is hiding somewhere in this
video yo yo raise your hand if you've
ever owned a yo-yo there's just
something about this simply designed toy
on a string that draws you in and makes
you practice your playing skills until
you get better the modern history behind
this yo-yo dates back to the 18th
century when the toy arrived in friends
you can even spot in this portrait of
the then future King Louie the 17th the
toy then made its way to England and
eventually the United States where the
craze officially began in the 1920s the
old version of yo-yo was made of raw and
simple materials however with modern
days this popular toy got a slightly
different look wondering if yo-yo is
still a thing it definitely is yo-yo has
actually developed into a full sport and
if you master the yo-yo tricks you might
have a chance to become a world champion
yes there are actual annual World
Championship events where the best
players battle it out and freestyle to
showcase their awesome tricks you'd be
surprised just how much you can do with
this simply design toy a yo-yo also
keeps your hands occupied helps you
maintain good focus and relieves mental
stress although it's not as popular as
the last toy in our list it's an awesome
alternative that's just as addictive
drones love the way remote-control cars
drones are the hottest newest toy on the
market and we're totally here for it
drones first started appearing in early
2016 and they were taking over the world
just a year later from being
professionally used in photography and
videography you're now also able to get
drone toys for children they come in all
shapes sizes and prices and are
so one of the most requested Christmas
list items we can definitely see why
think of it as a remote-control card
that is now able to also fly and record
what it's doing through its camera how
cool is that these drones are
specifically designed to be safe for
children they're flying ranges adjust to
the child's age and allow for plenty of
fun
John toys are extremely versatile and
apart from coming in many shapes they
are also priced in a way that won't
break your bank account so if driving
around a remote-control car was
addictive wait until you get your hands
on a toy drone much like the adult
version toy drones come with a pretty
impressive camera and the best can fly
up to 164 feet in the air with an
average of eight minutes of flying time
and if you're looking to combine drones
with remote-control cars you can get a
drone that's both Barbie dolls we've
covered hoverboards slimed Tamagotchi
Lego drones and Pokemon but there are
three toys out there that are much more
popular millions were sold they have a
fan base and they come with
controversies and we bet you have at
least one of the three in your house
ready to find out what the last three
toys are the first is the Barbie doll
owned by Mattel which is the biggest toy
maker in the world
the Barbie doll was launched in 1959 and
since then over 1 billion dolls were
sold Barbie doll had over 100 careers in
her life and brand-new doll collections
are still being made the best-selling
doll ever was the 1992 totally hair doll
which had long Rapunzel styled hair the
mission behind the dolls is to believe
you can achieve everything you set your
mind to from being a career girl and
paleontologist to a presidential
candidate and even a major league
baseball player these famous dolls let
young children discover a variety of
available careers
although Barbies are often criticized
for their lack of curves and body
diversity they are one of the most
beloved children's toys did you know
that Barbie's real name is Barbara
Millicent Roberts to find out more about
Barbie make sure you watch our amazing
facts you never knew about the Barbie
doll video
American Girl dolls and you know we
can't mention Barbie without mentioning
American Girl dolls it's a never-ending
debate which one is better let us know
in the comments which do you prefer and
why American Girl dolls were created in
1986 with the aim to portray the lives
of girls around the planet each doll
also comes with her own storybook work
you're able to find out a bit more about
her life upbringing and her goals the
company behind the American Girl doll
was called the pleasant company but they
sold the rights to Mattel in 1998 yes
the two doll rivals are actually owned
by the same company American Girl dolls
are much bigger and slightly more
realistic than Barbies as they portray
children this point the twist on the
regular Barbie doll as it helps kids
think that children can also do awesome
things not just adults and one of the
biggest differences and benefits of the
American Girl dolls is the diversity
you'll easily find a doll that looks
just like you since 1986
more than 155 million dolls were sold
and their catalog is the largest
consumer toy catalog in the country
these dolls are also timeless and can be
passed down from generation to
generation not only are they educational
they also have a sentimental value and
that's something many other toys on this
list don't have not even our last one
fidget spinners what is a fidget spinner
where did it come from and why is it so
popular all and more questions will be
answered in the next few seconds if
you're around teenagers often or you are
a teenager you are probably familiar
with the current craze called fidget
spinners these completely addictive toys
can be found absolutely everywhere if
you're not familiar with the fidget
spinner here's what it looks like
the rotating is proving to be a stress
relieving method for many kids that
suffer from ADHD and anxiety these
fidget spinners help students focus
relax and stay still so where did these
toys even come from it was originally
created by Catherine Hedden jerk who
first made the fidget spinner to promote
peace after she noticed kids throwing
rocks at the police
Catherine never thought the toys would
be the must-have gadget in 2017 you can
find fidget spinners in many different
shapes and sizes they're sold just about
anywhere which of course brings another
question are they really good for
calming your nerves or do they create an
even bigger distraction what such
popularity also comes a concern and many
schools ban these popular toys saying
they are a distraction and a safety
concern what do you think huh fidget
spinners help you concentrate what's
your favorite addictive toy let us know
in the comments below don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up for more videos
check out 10 most popular toys in
different countries see you next time
[Music]